when I was smart I would let them come
to me
just remote area
I've come into a remote area that's not
anywhere near where you live but that
other people going to is robbed there's
no clock
this is episode 99 that's right a 100 is
gonna be next week that's right and
we're actually recording this one kind
of earlier than we normally would just
so I have more time to work on yes the
one's gonna be kind of big that's kind
of complicated so we're gonna take Jenny
a couple days to get that video right
yeah cuz we have a lot of video of us
and stuff like that we kind of have to
edit together and yeah that's any two
different versions of video version and
an audio-only version because the video
will displace Audie it's too confident
you guys probably understand but yes
since that's gonna take me so long to do
I wanted to kind of get ahead on next
week so we're actually recording this on
the 4th of July that's right and Kayla's
gonna be right around the corner and
that looks like Jenny's actually could
probably got some rum right there that's
a rum son so that is a rum sunset yeah I
didn't make myself and I already I've
already drunk half of it yeah and I also
already finished off your birthday cake
yeah that's right
I'm not I'm not gonna have a drink I'm
just gonna power through this I'm a
muscle my way through this show I'm
gonna resist the temptation are you sure
yeah I think so you're funnier with that
you're funnier with the drink though
okay pause it
alright okay I'm back he's returned
yeah with Kela in Haines yeah it's like
a sunrise day that's probably like a
quadruple or a triple it's alright
though it's like I said it that's like a
bucket of tequila yeah you know what
[ __ ] this fourth of July that's not me
it's holiday I'm gonna find an excuse
anyway not like we didn't drink last
night
but yeah I'm just saying well that was
why I'm just like I'm not booze and cake
it's 4th of July whoo so if you hear
explosions in the background yeah it's
our neighbors it's our neighbors with
their fireworks yeah last year they had
like $1500 worth
yeah he's worth they said $1,400 with
the fireworks last year it did go on for
a long time I helped him with it it was
a lot of it was a lot yeah yeah they did
yeah it was going on so like two or
three it's not dark yet but if that
kicks up we won't be we won't be
recording by that late though any we're
probably not but yeah so if you hear
anything in the background that's all
that is nothing yeah it's not like we
don't live in Lake South Central or
anything like right sound samples
gentrified now everything's getting you
know but yeah so the topic we're doing
today not that not a real pleasant topic
for the holiday but you know that's
that's how it goes on this show we do
this is ooh pleasant sounds like a
mysteries of that explain type program
with unsolved murders and serial killers
and paranormal stuff and sometimes this
is gonna happen it's just got happens
yeah so this topic we're talking about
the serial killer Israel Keyes and this
has actually been requested at least
three times yeah at least three
different listeners Brooke I had heard
the guy's name I didn't know a great
deal about him so I've spent the last
few days delving into this dude and Wow
now I kind of wish I didn't know
anything about him yeah he's only about
it sounds like a real shitbird yeah now
here's this [ __ ] that's now
everything about him should be
introduced but yeah but from the
perspective of a true crime aficionado
such as myself and such as some of our
listeners yeah he is a very interesting
case study just because he deviates from
a lot of the standard serial killer kind
of patterns and also because no one
actually realized not only that he was a
serial killer but actually that there
were any murders at all right until you
know it under wraps for a long time yeah
until he was caught for a particular
thing and then they only retro actively
like found out about this [ __ ] so the
case is still wide open because all gone
absolutely know how many people are
killed so yeah so we're gonna get into
that a little bit later but first as
usual we're going to do our shout outs
if you have not
seeing our latest movie review it was
the 1978 movie Martin yeah George Romero
his vampire movie yeah cool flick it's a
very cool flick and so go check that out
if you haven't already for what it is
you know old 70s retro flick if you like
that kind of stuff if you like Night of
the Living Dead if you like vampire
movies it's about like that it's like a
gritty old 70s
yeah it's like what a little bit like
exploitation yes our house makes it feel
dirty watching it it's kind it looks
like digging through somebody's dad I
know that's why I like movies from the
70s good yeah they have that kind of
creepy aura about them also be sure to
check out our Zazzle store at zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock and i solve those for
new shirt designs that you can check out
Atlanta Ripper HH Holmes a couple other
ones they're pretty cool so go check
them out also if you would like to
financially support the show check out
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast up WordPress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account where you can give a
one-time donation I'd like to say hello
again to Kieran who he'd actually been
given on PayPal but he just recently
went back to patreon again okay so he's
so he's been contributing this whole
time but he just like moved he's moving
around from format the format which is
fine okay you can do whatever the hell
you want you honestly and also if you're
interested and want to go talk to other
fans of the show you can go to our 13
o'clock subreddit which our fan Duncan
started and I think all the episodes are
up now they each have a little forum so
you can go talk about it with other fans
I I'm a moderator on there but I have
I'm not on there that much but I'm gonna
try and be on there a little bit more in
the future
Oh before we get into the news stories I
wanted to just I wanted to mention this
entertaining little anecdote when
something that happened to us the other
day I know you talked yeah we went out
where where were we we went to the
grocery store grocery store or something
yeah and we were driving back into our
neighborhood and we're driving by this
house and the garage door was open and
we see a black bear
yeah cruising into the garage well you
saw it I didn't see it you told me yeah
we drove past and I was like yeah I was
like he was going into that that house
is a garage and I said there was a bear
in there anyway yeah yeah the driveway
it's a hold on I'm gonna get tell well
well be good here's the thing so he
backs up to the house and he pulls up
into the driveway and then I don't think
like I think you kind of got out of the
car rolled out the window it called to
him yeah and he kind of came out like a
wall yeah it was like looking at you and
he was looking at enough talking to him
and then you were kind of trying to get
him to like am-scray because the problem
is that I mean we have bears all over
the place yeah I've had him walk in on
me while I was working on the bikes yes
looking to look at me through the garage
door so what's up man come here if you
want to get rid of a bear just call it
time to come here and he's like yeah get
up come here bud come here oh well these
are yeah these aren't grizzly bears
these are black bears which um some of
them they get quite big yeah but they're
generally not all that aggressive the
only time they usually hurt people is if
somebody like [ __ ] with them or [ __ ]
with their babies actually no no not UPS
they're not too protective of them but
they don't like grizzly bears it's
usually some kind of a misunderstanding
and then sometimes there are just bad
black bears some black bears just don't
like people they're a pretty highly
evolved creature they're not an apex
predator they're just kind of like a
generalist they're scavengers yeah
they're likely around here the black
bears a lot like a really big raccoon
yeah
now Rocco could tear you up on the wrong
circumstances trail Ian but most of the
time they don't really want to [ __ ] with
you yeah they're pretty reasonable
actually yeah they make a lot of
displays and grunting and growling and
fake charges but a black bear they they
don't want trouble most of that and this
one was not even this was a juvenile he
was even a baby but he wasn't full-grown
because that's all grandmas got sighs
the large dogs yeah it was like a big
make like a big like a Rottweiler size
yeah but we kind of ran to Matt bring
him out of there yes the street he went
across the street and like looked like
way
I was looking for a garbage can why
can't I do that well because the reason
we did that and then we went and knocked
on the houses door was like hey am I
gonna close your garage door because
you're a bear just rain that old lady
was thrilled you is it you chased that
bear out of there yeah my ear oh well no
but the reason we wanted to do that was
because probably like a year year and a
half ago it might have been longer than
that not our neighborhood been
neighborhood like only a mile away from
here evidently like a woman walked out
into her garage and there was a bear out
there going through her garbage cans she
startled it and she would did she
accidentally had trapped it between the
wall and the parked car yeah and it was
kind of flipped out there which it felt
like it couldn't get out yeah there was
no way out of the garage except through
that woman and it charged her grabbed
her by the pant leg drugger yeah it
didn't kill her no then let her go yeah
it just kind of moved her out of the way
because it Ronix yeah and then it ran
away and then that woman yeah called
animal control yeah the Animal Control
people came and they ended up shooting
they exterminated a bunch of - man yeah
and and I knew some of those bears yeah
because we had seen some of those bears
around so and it was sad because I think
I came home from work while the animal
control guys were by our house because
there had been one around there yeah and
they were super bummed out they're like
man we really hate having to do this but
it's like you know the people all
they're complaining and they're like you
know these bears are getting in the
garbage - but you know I mean that's the
whole reason they tell you in this
neighborhood perfume we live kind of
it's not a rural area but there's a lot
of woods around there's a lot of farms
around the best one was I was in in that
in our bedroom and I had to even a
little the little shades and the shades
pulled cook that we'll go out to the
back patio and you were in here writing
a book and I saw what I thought was a
person out back there you know behind
there yeah open the shades and look
there's a big old bear bigger than a big
man and he was stretched out and laying
down on its side right there on the yeah
so sexy so I open up the door says he
bear I saw open up door what's up man he
jumped up ran towards that yeah oh no
towards the fence stood up grab the top
of the fence and did a pull up and
pulled himself over and fat ass over the
top of the fence and fell on the other
side but remember that yeah about two
years I remember seeing him climb yeah
going I didn't think I'll be able to
[Music]
Doran looked at him he saw me he
panicked around yeah they don't they
won't stand their ground and you know
they won't stand the ground and like I
say see people all the time because
they're sons I'm hanging out and say we
push it we seem I would be coming over
work sometimes see like two or three of
them like running through somebody's
backyard like whew you know what I mean
I've seen videos of people doing exactly
the wrong thing they see even those big
old black bears and they run so what's
the black bear dude she chases you yeah
because you're acting like yeah
something that they should eat
yeah they don't let you know they just
gallop alongside yeah where we go yeah
crazy well it's just kind of like they
tell you with a dog it's that better
than not sure if you turn around and run
away they're gonna bite you in the end
they run into any kind of bear best
thing do just greet the bear and walk
right towards it and that includes
grizzly bears and it won't know what to
do yeah well something it depends on big
grizzly bear but I've heard a lot of
grizzly bears have just run from you
most of the time unless you get that one
that crazy one that guy got eaten by
there was like he thought it was kind of
his body they just don't think it's
normal that you know prey doesn't walk
up to him yeah so they're always just
kinda like they're leery yes what is
this so yeah I thought I would just add
that in there because I was like I can't
believe it well at first I thought it
was just a dog and I'm like well hell
yeah it's broad daylight yeah we should
keep having the clubbers once it was
like two or three in the morning really
big huge black bear yeah stand up and be
probably nine foot tall black bear that
was a really big was a big ol black bear
yeah but he was he was very chill he was
just kind of like okay I'm going even
bigger than Chewbacca for about seven
feet yeah he was a very large bear yeah
but yeah that was pretty cool actually
all right so I just wanted to say that
kind of thing now I got before we get
into the Israel Keyes thing I got like a
couple of news stories again these are
ones that I just this is the news
thank you you gotta get I gotta get like
a purpose I thought you were gonna do it
like it like the Sweet Caroline this is
the news Jenny and Tom yeah I'm gonna
record that that was a cute Kela
assisted new song so yeah so these are
just like poor little stories that I got
from you know one of those news of the
weird sites that I thought was that I
thought were amazing or horrifying what
that fergus now this first one this took
place in the town of Teesside England at
22 well it's not G like te a like on the
side oh okay all right
it was just playing into some
stereotypes that I had I'm not gonna say
that that's good probably probably
drinking tea there's no way I like to
drink tea by drink iced tea
I'm southerner we were taught to you
something I drink cold tea with lemon in
it well sugar lots of sugar roses yeah
you need lots of sugar but I like Jackie
called a sweet tea yeah
okay so here's this guy from Teesside
England he's 22 years old as him is
jordan easton he was at his friend's
house they're hanging out in the kitchen
and all of a sudden he starts bragging
that his vest which i don't know if they
mean that in the American vernacular a
vest which is like you know a vest like
a Johnny juice because yeah I think in
in the UK vest I think it's kind of like
a wife beater okay same thing I find
it's t-shirt yeah if I'm thinking of the
right thing
so he says to his friend guess what my
vest is stab-proof okay get a sound that
sounded good already sounds an England
man story okay all right I got something
I got a related story but okay so okay
so he says my shirt is stab-proof
then he's like watch I will demonstrate
guess what happened I love okay I love
the way that this article phrases it the
assistant
foreigner which should tell you what
happened testified it says to prove it
he took hold of a knife to demonstrate
and sadly realized it wasn't the case
right yeah so yeah so he was taken to
the hospital doctors were unable to save
him I don't I guess he stabbed himself
in the chest like an idiot yeah
also they said that there was an inquest
several months later they said they
found no evidence easton intended to
harm himself and died after quote a
boisterous act yes he boisterously
stabbed himself there's such there's a
yeah there's like a video going around
on YouTube of a kid it's not the full
video although I'm sure you can probably
get the full video some young Hispanic
guy decided and his girlfriend he's
decided to do this stunt where he's
gonna hold a phonebook in front of his
chest and she's got him she's gonna
shoot him with a pistol and then he see
Mythbusters and the pistol round will be
stopped right the phone book
so okay that much that could be
plausible dependent upon the caliber of
the pitcher all right he selects a
desert eagle 50 action Express pistol
one of the most powerful handguns known
to man alright Dirty Harry's will be I
think it was the 475 Wildey Magnum what
I would have loved to been a 50 caliber
action Express boost and I haven't seen
it I believe it was she had him hold it
and she shot hit with it or he shot her
I don't know I didn't watch it I just
heard about it yeah telling you I don't
wanna watch that a phone book is not
gonna stop a 50 action Express route no
maybe some kind of lightweight
hollow-point but I bet you he grabbed
the cheapest round he could get which is
Full Metal Jacket and that's gonna be
armor-piercing that probably go through
six phone booths or font phonebook well
that's what you're always complaining
about ladies Julian action movies yeah
it's like you know he's like everybody
always hides behind a car door it's like
most know most rounds will go right
through a Paragon through seven or eight
car doors
especially in us alright so if I can go
through a car door or three then what
about pistol round 50 action Express you
know I mean it's not as much penetration
as like an assault rifle bullet but as
far as pistol rounds go lots of power
lots of power like the upper echelon it
killed whoever was on the other side of
that phone book I didn't see Tom if
you're gonna do this if you're gonna do
this stunt why don't you bring two phone
books and try it out first to make sure
that a phone book will stop that round
understand yeah you think let's just put
the phone books on the ground yeah okay
before we actually put our lives yes
yeah okay
but yeah ridiculous so since that last
one was England man yeah now here is a
Florida man okay this one is I'm right
man Putnam County Florida this is very
funny the way that was already sound
uneducated Putnam County yeah
the sheriff's office provides a wide
variety of services so when Douglas
Peter Kelly 49 woman enough to know
better
yeah call the office on June 12th to
complain that the methamphetamine he had
been sold was faked oh yes indeed yes
officers happily offered the tested form
yeah man and check that [ __ ] out
well they told detectives he had
suffered a violent reaction after
smoking the substance and wanted to sue
the dealer yeah I've been sold the wrong
drug yeah he forgot where he was he
arrived at the sheriff's office and
handed detectives a clear crystal like
substance wrapped in aluminum foil yeah
I love Owen the sheriff's office put
this on their Facebook page - yes they
probably thought this is the funniest
[ __ ] ever yeah so they put this funny
face paint it field tested positive
positive for methamphetamine Kelly was
arrested obviously so was it thank you
the real yeah remember our detectives
are always ready to assist anyone well
yes they were misled in their illegal
drug possum they put that on their
Facebook page hopefully he thought he
was in Grand Theft Auto didn't even have
an excuse I love that this is just kind
of
you remember all those like stories or I
don't know how many how many times this
actually happened there's probably just
one time and they blow it out of
proportion but you know some some
dumbass it was like on drugs or drunk or
whatever going through the McDonald's
drive-through and they didn't have you
know fish sandwich and she's calling 911
or something yeah you know it's that
kind of [ __ ] so there's the same kind of
thing it's like I got fake drugs I'm
gonna see that's ridiculous yeah just
bring it on down here and he did I'm a
proud Florida resident myself proud
proud of all these men from Florida they
just want what's coming to them guys
it's hilarious hilarious I love this
[ __ ] all right
now this one is actually pretty horrific
this is this actually right here this is
one of my worst nightmares so this woman
her name is Wat Eva she's 54 years old
she disappeared on June 14th while
tending her vegetable garden on muna
island in the South East Sulawesi
province of Indonesia her family found
only her sandals a machete and a
flashlight in the garden but just 50
yards away
villagers located a 23 foot long Python
okay with a severely bloated midsection
don't tell me Python hater yes I didn't
think that was possible they reported
that when the snake's belly was cut open
it revealed the woman's fully intact
body inside still wearing all her
clothes
damn how tall was she she had to been a
truth she might have a really small
woman they said one of the villagers
said it looked like a horror movie yeah
yeah I guess it must have yeah did I
guess is Emma
well that minutes rude to say that but
why did they kill the snake the snakes
just doing what it does I mean you know
I just say to see if she was in there I
guess uh I mean you know you got to find
out where she went that was a pro that
was a prized snake sucker had to be huge
oh my three feet swallowed a woman it's
too late though I might as well just let
it digest ooh I don't know though I mean
you know I I see what you're saying I
like snakes I'm not I'm not one of those
people that's all like one that size but
yeah well I don't know that they want
I need you so get the body back you want
to worry about burial yeah yes it's
Indonesia then maybe they have 23 foot
Python delivery boy baby because I kind
of feel like these big pythons are I
don't think they're common but I don't
think they're all that uncommon either
although most of the ones you see
pictures of on the internet and YouTube
and they are super shot but I have seen
some pretty [ __ ] big ones really did
pretty well real honestly there's a lot
of like really super unpleasant ways to
die right in my top five is being
swallowed by something yeah she was dead
by the time that happened constricted
her she was such well yeah I know but
it's still I getting eaten by a shark or
a crocodile
I saw a video of a guy in India getting
killed by a snake did you see that thing
they didn't know how to help him he was
putting on yeah goddesu he was putting
on some kind of snake show he was like a
sidewalk entertainer and he had a big
old some kind of Python boa constrictors
Allah it was a large constrictor I'd say
probably about four and a half five
inches in diameter at its thickest and
he was putting on some kind of snake
show and it had wrapped around his let
his neck and started to constrict and
they thought it was part of the Act they
were just watching until it was too late
they realized that he was dead they got
the snake off of him but he didn't
revive yeah although I did not see
anybody trying to resuscitate him which
I don't know how long it had been but it
may not have been that long I'm not sure
if they know about CPR in the Indian
look like something down in the hood of
India going on that's that's pretty more
than ladies I could Slumdog Millionaire
type yeah like you said it's if it was
part of a show and it thought it was
part of you and me
oh no yeah they were watching it yeah
and they're like oh wow that looks real
yeah yeah we see that on you see that on
YouTube no thanks
there are some things it's like I kind
of hear about it and I'm like yeah I can
imagine that aren't really that you can
tell I don't think they really showed
the whole thing for me I remember it was
just like it was a news report yeah
whose report had pictures of them trying
to get it off of him yeah I mean I still
kind of have nightmares about seeing
that guy that got his arm bit off an
alligator and the alligator was like a
hand sticking out of their mouth it's
like that really disturbed gonna have to
go down to this pub over here
jump in there with my knife and go get
an alligator get it on get it on video
we put it up here on the show badass I
have you said no I'm not gonna jump in
there and grab that alligators yeah he's
probably well I don't know how many are
in there but they're probably not big if
it's I hear them I hear them making
their little noise smaller this smaller
than fives me for smaller than five feet
I could probably get him out of there
I wouldn't go for anything bigger than
that you know I've been near those 12
footers yeah grab them guys no no no no
my widget why on earth would you do that
your abs gonna be another Florida man's
got a grit you gotta grab him by the
nose and hold his ball yeah because they
can't his mouth shut
yeah because they don't Danno they can't
open if you just like hold you can just
hold the show cuz you keep not like I'm
gonna do it but I'm just you know they
got a powerful tail though so yeah be in
deep water no they'll start thrashing
I've have the research exactly where you
got to stand to bring him under control
yeah no that'd be some badass [ __ ] yeah
okay if I get hurt even better even
better get more hits this is like I said
you heard it here first hold my [ __ ]
beer
this is hold my Keela Oh Mikey this is
gonna be a Florida man story waiting
alright so the next the next news story
very short this happened in Auckland New
Zealand an unnamed 28 year old man
appeared in court June 18th to answer
charges of stealing two human toes from
the body world's vital exhibition what
what for I don't know okay I actually
that but that body world's exhibition is
pretty cool I saw it like several years
ago when it was in Tampa it's all those
people that are like you know peeled and
they that was in that first James right
yeah it was that same traveling show it
traveled all around I saw it many years
ago but yeah so for some reason this guy
goes to the body world's exhibition in
New Zealand and just plucks two toes off
he's like okay I'm out of here I'm gonna
put these in my pocket maybe Ben maybe
thought you can ransom him back who
knows but you know I he he got caught
for I don't know how the toe is
evidently were valued at fifty five
hundred dollars each so there you go but
they have been returned to the
exhibition and the tenth the toe thief
is looking at seven years in prison
dumbass and
two years for interfering with the dead
body damn ass some like yeah those are
human remains
even though certain guys just don't
think it through you know I mean they
don't think it through well most guys
don't think it through you must consider
the legal penalties for your actions the
world would be a better place if more
people I feel like more people some
things are a variable though
some things are avoidable stealing two
toes that's last donated plaster that's
not you need a passion that's not heat
of passion and heat of the moment type
of thing that sounds like a very
specific weird crime and why I need to
do they're not in a pissing match with
another man that's gonna drive you to
insanity you know as buddy some kind of
fight or anything like that this is
you're sitting there and you're looking
at some toes gonna pop up take those
steel those two I just that's not that's
not gonna cross my mind that I see some
toes oh wow it is almost other people's
minds are a mystery to me really
hardwired this is in New Zealand yeah I
thought we had crazy people there's
crazy people I can't get it's not just
our affliction yeah I guess yeah I just
think we just have more of them all
right so now let's get into talking
about Israel Keyes yeah I've been
looking forward to this you first
started to tell me about this kid in
this case we were out doing our walks
yeah like I said this this is something
that's been requested a lot of times and
from all the research I've been doing
into it there's several documentaries
about it I was on you know the web
sleuths forum and apparently there's I
mean there's really a lot of interest in
this case maybe I guess because it's
fairly recent but also because it's kind
of weird because it almost happened the
way that he was discovered it almost
happened like in Reverse because usually
you know you have when there's a serial
killer you have a bunch of interrelated
victims and somebody's like okay well
the same person is killing all these
people and then eventually that person
gets caught or not but they generally
know that it's you know that it's going
on they're like this is the signature of
this killer or whatever
yeah but in this case apparently this
guy had been killing people for they
think 14 years and no one knew anything
damn it just so has been I'm like under
the radar serial killer he used a
stealth serial killer they even know
existed they didn't even know he existed
because he travelled around so much no
bodies were found he's ninja yeah it was
kind of like that that's kind of the the
most fascinating thing about this so the
problem becomes that when he eventually
got caught they really they could only
pin three murders on him right you know
but from all these interviews and stuff
like that he hinted that there were at
least seven eight more maybe as many as
twelve more but he wouldn't say who they
were where they were or anything and
then he killed himself
hmm so now there's huge I mean like I
said I went on the web solutes thing
there's huge forums where people are
trying to track down his movements
during all this 14-year period like
where was he you know you know were
there missing-persons cases in the area
that could have been like him taking a
victim and [ __ ] like that it's just like
this creepy creepy case he's really
unlike pretty much any other serial
killer I've ever read about all right
there's just something about it he's
just the he's the [ __ ] worst I mean
they're all bad yeah but this guy just
seemed like I mean not only he was one
of those double life I'm leading a
double life [ __ ] right and like
he seemed totally normal and [ __ ] yeah
but then he was doing all this [ __ ] on
the side although I watched some of the
interviews like we go on YouTube there's
hours and hours and hours and hours of
like the FBI interviews with him you
know over the months like after his
capture and even though pretty much
everybody that knew him like said oh he
was kind of a likable guy and you know
he seemed totally normal and stuff like
that to me he seemed a little smarmy he
seemed a little he seemed like an edge
Lord to be honest he seemed kind of like
I'm smarter than everybody and I'm in
control of everything and he was just
very you know so evil and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so and you know and I hate
people like that so he
came across very much like that to me
like I don't that obviously wasn't his
natural environment because he was you
know under arrest and everything but
that's how you so I can't really see how
people thought he was likable but you
know I'm willing to give other people
who benefit of the doubt so what I
wanted to do like I kind of thought
about well how am I gonna talk about him
how am I gonna do like a timeline I
think what I was gonna do I was gonna go
back and talk about [ __ ] like from the
beginning but I think what I'm gonna do
is structure it the same way that people
found out about it like the time he got
caught for because no playing I said
nobody knew until he got caught for this
one crime and then they found out of all
these other right before we go to the
break though I know you're you're
talking about how he was kinda like an
edge lord but he's a really out of all
these serial killers that we've covered
so far and all the ones I can think of
off the top of my head I wouldn't afraid
to any of these guys none of those guys
scared me on a personal level there's
only one dude that scared me like when I
hear him talking when I when I hear him
talking and that's kuklinski the Iceman
and he was a mafia hit man and what
really scared me about that guy was just
his cold professional he did this [ __ ]
for a living yeah and that's the only
guy that really kind of like what you
hear him talking
you know that yeah he could kill you
well in some ways I think this guy had a
similar vibe because he didn't have a
particular reason he didn't have a
particular victim profile he just wanted
to kill people because he liked it and
he didn't particularly care who it was
he didn't care if he particularly got
anything out of it he just liked to do
it and he you know would go all over the
country and go through all these like
really elaborate you know elaborate
setup to do it just because he enjoyed
it that's pretty much the only reason he
ever gave I think when they asked him
because the FBI guy saw like an
interview with one of the FBI guys who'd
interviewed him and he said you know at
one point we were just like you know
what you know why why did you do it all
he said was why not yeah he just he did
not give a single shot I almost see that
as a weakness though in a way yeah I
mean it's almost like he can't he has
these perverted urges and he can't
resist them Kuklinski wasn't like that
Kuklinski killed you because he was
hired to kill you you you were a
gangster you did something wrong he was
hired to kill you take you out or you
made him mad he made him mad there
just something to me to me this the
holding the only one that intimidated me
just through interviews was kuklinski
meeting a guy like that I'd have to
really work hard to keep my balance
around it peanut was all about
kisses s no I'd be as polite as I could
be polite as respectful as I could ya
know like I said I think the creepy
thing about Israel Keyes was that like I
said for years and years he just lived a
completely normal life he had a business
he had a girlfriend he had a daughter
nobody had any [ __ ] clue about
anything and he looked normal he acted
normal you know it but you never knew
like when and he he picked people
totally totally at random didn't have
anything to do with them what they
looked like what they just didn't matter
so in a way like I said he's interesting
from that point of view it's like just
from a criminal profiler point of view
because he was he's kind of different to
a lot of the other ones like his
motivations seemed kind of different so
I'm kind of glad that he got requested
because I don't know if I would have
necessarily done a show about him if
somebody hadn't yeah recommended it but
I'm actually really now I'm kind of all
into it and I want to kind of help us
solve like old that would help solve
like all these other crimes that you
probably committed what should we go
ahead and take a break when you come
back you lay it laid out yeah let's do
that because we're getting about to the
halfway point okay so we're gonna take a
break right now I'm gonna refill my
drink and then we will come back and get
into the case of serial killer is real
keys we will be back in just a minute
okay everybody
Jenni's got some new shirt designs up
four of them really good ones to Atlanta
Ripper who put Bella in the which out
the HH Holmes murder castle and of
course demon child cuz man said he could
these are updated designs I think they
look really cool Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out really good
they're very high-quality shirts Jenny
and I we're sure our own shirts at
certain times when we're trying to put
spotlight on ourselves and you can put a
spotlight on yourselves if you go ahead
and pick up on these shirts today you
guys are gonna love them links in the
description WWL comm at 13 o'clock yeah
so go check out our store at wwl comm 13
o'clock we got these four cool new
t-shirt designs plus all our old ones a
few
there get one at old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out
they're also available in women's cut
and they look really cute Judy's got
some so thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so let's get into talking
about this like I said I kind of want to
start at the end I suppose because I
want to start with the crime that got
him caught now I should know that the
only reason that we know about him at
all as a serial killer is because of
this particular crime and the only
reason we know about this particular
crime is because he had started to get
sloppy
yeah prior to this you know he was very
under the radar because he had rules he
was always like I'm gonna go somewhere
thousands of miles away from where I
live I'm gonna pick somebody at random
out in the woods I'm just gonna kill him
and dump him in a lake somewhere no
one's ever gonna find them so no one's
ever gonna know ever gonna know they
were even murdered right so he was doing
that apparently for a very long time but
for whatever reason I guess because like
I said he seemed very much like a thrill
killer yeah so I kind of feel like he
was getting the point where he just
wanted to get more and more ballsy
because he wasn't getting the rush that
he used to get anyone so he wanted to do
something more brazen I suppose so this
happened in Anchorage Alaska now he was
actually living there at the time which
is something he would normally would not
do you normally wouldn't commit a crime
anywhere near where he lived so that was
kind of the first thing he had lived in
Alaska for quite a while he had a
girlfriend in Kimberly Andrews he had a
daughter I believe it was from a
previous relationship the daughter was
10 or 11 and this was this happen in
2012 so the daughter was 10 or 11 at the
time they had a house just totally
normal he had a contracting company he
built houses did handyman work he was
apparently very well-respected made a
lot of money so you know no one thought
anything was amiss so this happened in
February 2012 in Anchorage there was
like a little like a roadside coffee
kiosk little coffee stand called common
grounds that's a great name for a coffee
shop in a common ground well a lot of
them were named that are they yeah it's
funny because coffee shops and
hairdressing salons they always have to
have pawn names so I feel like it's the
first time I've ever heard of it
yeah there's there's a lot name that oh
oh yeah so working in this coffee stand
there was an 18 year old girl named
Samantha Koenig and she's closing up
this store at about 8 p.m. and it's
February so it's like there's a bunch of
snow it's like you know it's Alaska it's
freezing cold and a guy walks up to the
coffee stand now he has a ski mask on
but it's Alaska in February like
everybody's got a ski mask so it's not
if she was not alarmed the guy asked for
an Americano she turns around to make it
now I should say if you want to check
this out on YouTube it's a little
disturbing to watch there is actually
security cam footage of all this
abduction so I've seen it it's it's
creepy big avoid if you know what
happened to her but you know I don't
really know if I want to put in the
video or anything but it's on youtube if
you want to see it's about 11 12 minutes
long so she turns around to make the
drink and then she turns around and says
have you know however much money it is
and then he's pointing a gun at her then
he tells her to turn off the lights he
told her to take all the money out of
the cash register and then he tells her
to sit down on the floor of the kiosk
and he's kind of looking around because
there's cars there's like a Home Depot
or some [ __ ] like across the street
there so far as if it's only eight
o'clock at night right it's like a
Wednesday night or something so he looks
around and then he jumps in through the
serving window and he binds her hands
with zip ties now he takes her out of
the kiosk and puts her in his car takes
her back to his house which is
apparently not that far away puts her in
a shed near his house and then he
realizes oh I left a bunch of zip ties
that have my fingerprints on them and I
left her cellphone at the coffee kiosk
so he drives back to the kiosk yeah and
he kind of scoops it out make sure the
cops aren't there I mean it hasn't been
that long right you know it was a case
where I mean she'd been at work her
boyfriend was gonna come pick her up but
it hadn't been so much time that
everyone like where the hell is she you
know what I mean so he actually which
was kind of ballsy like I said he drove
back to the place he got the zip ties he
got the cell phone and then he goes back
to the shed now I guess I'll say I'll
say this right away because there was
some [ __ ] later on where they thought
she might still be alive for a really
long time that he encouraged I should
say right but basically he
raped and strangled her our - after he
brought her to the thing now he leaves
her body in the shed later that there
the very next day he had already booked
a cruise I think him and his daughter
were going on a cruise
damn and he had booked it before and he
was gonna be gone for like two weeks or
something old was he when he did this 34
okay and how old was his daughter ten or
eleven okay I don't think his girlfriend
went it seems like some of the
reenactments I saw it looked like he
took his daughter with him I'm not sure
but but he had booked a vacation so he
had been planning to kill this girl
right leave it and then I'm gonna go on
vacation for two weeks whatever so then
he comes back from this vacation in the
meantime yeah this poor girl has been
reported missing nobody has any idea
where she is it's this little town
there's like Flyers everywhere her
family is freaking out and then he
decides oh well I guess I'm gonna get
some money out of this [ __ ] now you
might have been planning this from the
beginning I'm not really sure right so
he has her cell phone so he sends a text
from her phone to either her parents or
her boyfriend sources differ and say I
want $30,000 for her return you know
he's he leaves the ransom note he's like
I'll leave the ransom note like in this
park underneath this flyer or whatever
and then he takes a picture of her body
yeah but he prompts her up against the
wall and sews her eyelids open so it
looks like she's still alive how long
and now it's a winter time she'd been
dead within the ship in a couple of
weeks yes she must've been kind of
frozen yeah so that's why she preserved
yeah because in the picture you would
not I've seen the picture see the cuz
she doesn't look dead no I mean it's a
crappy picture it's like you know it's
blurry and stuff but it's it but it
doesn't look like a dead person wow
that's really creepy and he took a
picture of her like he took a picture of
her and then like a newspaper from like
a daze who's like see she's still alive
on this date or whatever so you start so
he sends that over there was so yeah and
her eyes are open you can see yeah it
looks like man yeah I wouldn't know yeah
I said I saw the picture I'm like oh my
god she's been dead for
yeah but if you couldn't tell though
from the picture I mean nothing than
what I saw so the parents are like oh
alright she's still alive now the
parents did not have $30,000 but they
very quickly they made a public appeal
they got the money now Israel Keyes says
deposit the money in her account but he
has her ATM card and before he killed
her he got her selling the pin number
right so you know he can access this
money now right here's like I said
here's where he got stupid well the
first thing that was stupid was that he
attacked somebody in the town he lived
in which he had never done before right
- he didn't check the coffee kiosk for
security cameras I mean you couldn't see
him because I had a mask on and he was
just like a shadow there were no lights
and the thing probably didn't care so he
might not have cared because he's like
oh they won't see me when I think that
he'd make it identifying by his clothing
his build I think he's from that town
yeah I think there's ago I know that
well no I mean he wasn't a native of
there okay he actually came from Utah
and then he lived in Washington State
for a long time then he moved to Alaska
like in 2007 or something 2007 or 2009
so he hadn't lived there his whole life
the other stupid thing he did was that
after that he started making withdrawals
from her account at this point like I
said the police and her family were
still kind of thinking she was still
alive they're like oh she's taking money
out and maybe they're still together but
then as the week's went on they're like
okay she's probably dead and whoever
this is it's taking money out of her
account so at this point they're like
okay so they have it pinged up where
every time somebody withdraws money from
that account they know where it is and
there's no cameras where he's drawing
cuz you say yeah yeah I was gonna get to
that but so he starts traveling so they
keep digging him in like New Mexico and
then finally he ends up in this town
called Lufkin Texas what ended up
happening there was that when he got to
Texas and he was taking money out of the
ATM he had a mask on at the AC because
he knows there's a camera on the ATM
right right but you could see his rattle
car in the back ahaha and it was a I
believe it was a white Ford Focus so at
that point they put out a bolo which
would be on the lookout they're like for
a big six-foot to white dude in a rental
white Ford Focus right and he's from
Alaska so if you pull him over and he
has
like an Alaskan driver's license then
you'll know who this is so they didn't
know who he was at this point they just
knew this is the person that's taking
money out of this missing girls account
so a guy a patrol cop in Lufkin Texas
sees a white Ford Focus and sees a big
white guy driving it as soon as that guy
goes a little bit over the speed limit
he's like I'm pulling that [ __ ] over so
he pulled it over inside the car is
Samantha Koenig's stolen debit card her
cell phone with the battery removed in
rolls and rolls of cash now at this
point they can't charge him with
anything except access device fraud
which is taking money out of someone
else's account without their permission
because they don't know where she is
they don't know if she's still alive or
whatever so they arrest him for that and
they extradite him back to Alaska now
while they have him in custody they're
just like well you know we're issue just
tell us where she is then he says well
she's dead I filled her and then they're
like well where is she where's her body
so they finally got him to tell them
that after you know he had taken the
picture the body and everything he had
basically gone out to this lake I think
it's called like men Tuscon or something
like that like north of Anchorage and he
had pretended he was ice fishing like he
had built a little shelter and
everything like you do when you're ice
fishing he had cut up her body and
dropped it into the lake he remembered
the exact coordinates where he had
dumped the body because the cops went
there and found it like within a couple
of hours huh now it should be noted that
this is the only body of any of his
victims that has ever been found they
know that there's more but they don't
know where they are and they don't know
how to find them Samantha Koenig was
found so after that whole thing the FBI
are interviewing this jackal and the way
he's talking they're kind of like okay
there's more to this this is not the
first time that this guy has done this
then the guy's like okay well you got me
blah blah blah and then he's like well
I'll tell you what I'll start telling
you some things if you make things go
the way I want now he made a very weird
request he basically said I want the
death penalty within a year that's what
he said you trying to get out there yeah
so he's like I want this over with as
quickly as possible he seemed like he
was concerned about his image
in the sense that he didn't want his
daughter growing up and googling him and
then seeing all this [ __ ] attributing
that that's attributed to her dad should
have thought of that before you dude
that's what I said I was like why didn't
I think about before you thing is crap
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I mean it's
like I was like whatever if they never
do that though there's like their
thoughts about him I don't want to look
bad because he even said because like I
said I've seen like a bunch of
interviews snippets with him and he's
even saying he's like oh the more stuff
that gets attributed to me I could get
more they're gonna make some one of
those stupid TV shows yeah I can
understand it you're gonna go ahead and
do all this [ __ ] and you're not gonna
and you don't want to look bad I mean if
you're gonna do this man you better own
it well that was another thing that this
thing weird about this guy is through
before you is that I mean particularly
previously to Samantha Koenig's murder
it seems like you know how a lot of
serial killers seem to have this need
for attention and like indeed for
self-aggrandizement yeah and like some
of them will even like confess the [ __ ]
they did yeah I think somebody got
themselves like a bigger badder yeah I
think Albert Fish actually made some of
his crimes up yeah a lot of them they
inflate you know they would you know
they kind of confabulate to make
themselves look more evil voice Gary
this guy almost seemed like he didn't
want that weird
like he wanted to kill people anyway but
he didn't want anybody to know like he
don't want to be associated only he
mattered other people didn't matter he
was yet impressed that yeah well I want
anything read our that's and he said
exactly that how did he okay he said
exactly that he said that was his thing
I just wanted to kill people and get
away with it he didn't really care about
being famous
right um he specifically said I don't
want any of those stupid [ __ ] true
crime shows made about me I was like
except [ __ ] buddy right now bro be well
well I'm like I said there have been a
bunch of them today like dark Minds did
want and a British show did one himself
that's what's weird it's like his
motivation was almost like and in fact
like a lot of his early crimes that they
think that he committed he didn't even
like some of them are not even they
don't they don't know where the bodies
are they're just they're either
missing-persons cases or nobody even
knows that there was a crime committed
so what happened next I mean he's in
so he goes in there and he says okay I
want the death penalty within a year and
I will give you a couple things so it
seems like he was having this power play
where I'm gonna get what I want and I'll
just give you feed you a little bit of
information at a time because he knew
that if he didn't tell them any of the
[ __ ] they would never find out right and
they still haven't so I guess he was
right so he said well I'll give you two
bodies
he said the courier case Vermont look
that up so they did so they called
Vermont and they're like do you have an
unsolved murder of somebody called the
courier's and they're like yes we do
they're like it's not an unsolved murder
it's missing persons right and they're
like what happened with these two and
this is like super creepy this happened
in June 2011 and it was in this little
town called Essex Junction Vermont
evidently what Israel Keyes had done at
some point in about 2009 he had been
driving around in Vermont because he did
all these kind of trips he didn't kill
people on every trip they don't think
right but he would go sometimes years
ahead and he would see a good location
he's like oh maybe one day in the future
I'm gonna get a victim from there so I'm
gonna get ready right so in 2009 about
two miles away from these people's house
he had buried a five-gallon bucket and
it had guns in it it had rope duct tape
Drano which is something that he used to
make bodies decompose faster a roll of
cash so he makes he called them kill
cancer murder breath and he would bury
them like out in the woods somewhere
near where the location was so when he
decided to come back and kill the people
in that area he would have it there so
he didn't have to transport it a long
way so evidently he had one there that
had been there since of 2009 in 2011 he
actually flew to Chicago under his own
name
he bought tickets under his own name he
rented a car in Chicago he drove the
thousand miles to Vermont
he went to these these people's House
bill in the rain courier bill was 49 and
Lorraine was 55 they had lived there you
know long time he's a really nice little
house he said the only reason that he
picked that house was because it was a
small town it looked like you could get
into the house through the garage he
could tell where the master bedroom was
and they didn't have any children or a
dog
he said that was that was the only
reason all right so basically in the
middle of the night he breaks a window
very quietly in the garage and he goes
through to the house and he just goes up
to their room wakes them up with a gun
makes them turn over finds their hand
was with zip ties and he's like get in
your car we're going somewhere else they
both get in their car he drives them to
this abandoned farmhouse that he had a
you know scoped out earlier he takes the
guy down to the basement and ties him to
a chair or a stool and then he goes out
to get Lorraine now some sources say
that Lorraine actually kind of ran away
you know or kind of tried to get away
and then he caught her and dragged her
back but some sources you know some
documentaries didn't mention that some
did so I don't know but he actually did
catch her when he was bringing her
inside he brought her inside and raped
her meanwhile her husband had gotten
loose yeah down in the basement now he
came down there and the guy was loose
and he kind of like started yelling and
jumping at him
so Keyes picked up a shovel and just
whacked him in the head and then shot
the husband right in front of the woman
and then he strangled her to death
then he kind of wrapped the bodies in
plastic and then poured Drano on them
and then just left them there right so
nobody knew what had happened to these
people because it looked like in their
house all they found was like a broken
window right there gun was missing
because he had taken it nothing else was
really stolen I don't think he and
ransacked it or anything nothing else
appeared disturbed so it just looked
like this couple of just up and vanished
their car was gone and all this other
[ __ ] so they didn't know what had
happened to them for all this time now
the barn whose barn was this it's like
abandoned it was abandoned it was for
sale okay he's like it was old and it
was per se he had seen it like another
run through the town right so the people
nobody really owned it or was in
transition so nobody noticed anything
anything else yeah absolutely did you do
with the body so did you say it just
left that just left him yeah he just
left him in the basement abandoned
farmhouse and then you just took off but
like I said nobody knew where they were
now by the time he told the FBI about
what had happened to them what about
what he had done they caught you know
when they called Vermont and they said
okay we're gonna go he told him exactly
where that farmhouse was but by the time
the investigators got there the far
house had been torn down they didn't
notice it's all gone now we'll see they
said when they went back and asked the
people that had torn down the thing they
said oh we did smell something bad but
we just thought it was like deer was
hunting country so they just figured it
was like deer carcasses or something
like that they weren't really concerned
about it so they just kind of scooped
the whole thing up and took it to the
landfill they actually did spend seven
weeks going through the landfill but
they couldn't find anything okay so the
bodies were not say the bodies were
never found
but he knew so many specific details
about the crime that they knew that that
had to be what it happens then because
he knew the land house he knew exactly
and everything like checked out so those
were the only two those are the only
three crimes so Samantha Koenig they
know that was him and then the couriers
it's amazing how a murders double
homicide like that can go undiscovered
yes accidentally lost yes because well
I'm like I said they go I mean they knew
they were gone and that was weird
because they said that was unusual for
them to just take off like that I just
could just think they dismantle our and
they don't even check with snow it had
been hello had it been well he was
caught in March 2012 so it was like oh
it was like more than a year later you
shouldn't have been smellin a year later
well I don't know what it was or down
like a row it was torn down melted back
on tween there so then and like I said
this is the shitty thing and why this
guy was such a [ __ ] taint because the
Tate because he so he gave them the
couriers it was like okay I did that
yeah because he knew they had him anyway
right and that was a maneuver to get the
death penalty within a year he's like I
want it within a year which you know
that never happens what are they talking
about
and honestly he got arrested in Alaska
then he had the death penalty in Alaska
they do in Washington state so I think
maybe he might have been wanting to get
extra extra into Washington State but
here's the thing he wouldn't tell
investigators enough like he told them
enough for them to figure that he
probably did like I said at least seven
more probably more than that but there's
nothing specific enough you've just
teased them what he was pretty much just
teasing them now they do think that one
of the ones they're not
absolutely certain about this one but
there was a missing persons case that
took place in April of 2009 and this was
a woman I think she was 50 her name is
Deborah Feldman and she lived in New
Jersey she was kind of a drug addict to
prostitute yeah now she went missing in
April 2009 and they think that Israel
Keyes from clues that he said when he
was being interviewed that he probably
kidnapped her and drove her to upstate
New York raped and killed her and then
probably dropped her in a lake because
he was into that he liked to ferment
Lakes put him in lakes um he eat and he
mentioned something too about Crescent
Lake in Washington so they think there
might be some bodies in there but it's
too deep and too cold to check what she
knew because he said that in the
interview he also um so they think that
he probably killed Deborah Feldman also
because he was in the area and they know
that he was in the area because the day
after she went missing he robbed a bank
in a village right by there and that's
another thing too that was another way
that he funded his kill trips robbed but
he robbed banks they have footage of him
robbing too bad they didn't know it was
him cuz he wore a disguise but after he
told them oh I robbed he robbed a bank
in Tupper Lake like kind of a small town
in upstate New York and then they found
the footage Sam did he ever really come
out with a definitive number no that's
what I mean to this day so you don't
know he said he was gonna give him
Tuesday buddies
Curt the courier's okay fill in the
rancher wasn't two cases it he said two
bodies okay I'm gonna give you two body
and he said he say he had more yes
well because they asked him they said
why he stopped negotiating because he
liked having power over them that he had
information they didn't have one of
these things this was kind of
interesting from a psychological point
of view because I was just like watching
him talk and listening to the stuff he
was saying he seemed to get off on and I
think this kind of ties in with the
whole he didn't really want
self-aggrandizement he didn't want the
media knowing about him because he said
that after the courier's after he killed
the couriers and this was you know like
a year before he got caught they're like
well he's like I would go to the library
because he didn't want to use his own
computer because they can check like
your Google search
stuff like that so he's like I would go
to the library and look at the Vermont
news cuz he was in Alaska you know and
see how they were going with the case
and it would kind of chuckle because
they didn't have any idea that Remmy so
he kind of got off on knowing something
that nobody else knew right because that
was something that he said a lot that
nobody knew me like nobody knew the room
and nobody ever saw this side of me
actually dark Minds the true crime
series they actually did a two-hour
special on this dude right and they were
interviewing a guy who had hired Israel
Keyes liked to do he's like built an
extension on his house not like that
he'd been like working for six months
he's like this was the craziest thing
he's like I couldn't believe it he's
like I knew this guy like he was totally
nice it's like he turned up every
morning's totally normal it's like he
was a very hard worker his work was very
good it was really beautiful it's like
he was very focused he was very you know
what I mean
like I said he had a girlfriend she had
no idea the daughter no idea everybody
thought he was completely normal but
that was kind of part of his little
power play was that nobody knows that I
fly out to all these remote locations
like hiking trails and just kill people
for no reason and then dump him in a
lake in nobody even knows it was me
there's just missing persons case was
there anything about his early
background that may be created yeah
there's okay this is like a lot of
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] going on
with this he was actually born in Utah
to a very large Mormon family he had
eight or nine brothers and sisters maybe
just sisters so it was a very big family
he was home-schooled yeah it was very
very very strict upbringing which
happens a lot with serial killers I've
noticed then they moved to like Eastern
Washington State there's kind of like a
real kind of rednecky kind of area yeah
they actually live next door to this
rather infamous family called the Kehoe
family who were in this weird like
Christian white supremacy cult okay he
was kind of buddies with a couple of
them they were later convicted of like
murdering a whole family and brought
them in a swamp or some [ __ ] it's
getting dark in there
not fireworks yeah yeah so you know so
there was that whole dynamic he did
actually come forward and say he
rejected religion so he was very much
the dark minds documentary said that he
actually had a brand of an upside-down
cross and a pentagram so I was like I
was one of those that's why I be agile
or he's not like so he was kind of like
trying to rebel against his religious
background I guess cuz he claimed he was
an atheist but I was like he sounded
like he wanted be like I'm too badass
you know it was that kind of thing this
is so not like a real atheist he was
just you know what I mean he was just
kind of like I just want to like piss
people off right thing that was really
subversive where he came from yeah I
guess that's exactly what it is he
wanted to seem like he was super
subversive he just loved what the other
direction now he told a story to the FBI
that when he was a teenager I want to
say 14:15 that you know he had always
hunted he was a very outdoorsy guy he
was in the military
later on I'll kind of talk about that in
a second you know he would go out in the
woods and build cabins and [ __ ] like
that but he evidently took a cat that
their family had that kept getting in
the garbage can he took it out in the
woods with his friends and he tied it to
a tree and shot it in the stomach
BAM and then watched it while it was
like running around the tree like dying
radicular and he thought it was funny
and then he said that he turned around
and his friend that was with him was
like throwing up and lo it was like
obviously upset if like a normal person
would be yeah and he's like oh well
that's when I realized that you know
stuff that I thought was okay was not
okay
right and I'm like really did you I mean
but so he just seemed very sociopathic
even though he did seem to love his
daughter I mean nobody ever thought that
would have loved his girlfriend nobody
thought there was anything going on
right by into that most of those
sociopaths love their daughter and love
their girlfriends because it's a
reflection on them if they dumped them
they look like [ __ ] heels yeah good you
trying to show other people well you
know that they're good yeah it's just
you know to make their image seem better
yeah so he actually he was in the
military for a little while three or
four years he was at Fort Hood he was at
Fort Lewis and he did some time on side
Egypt yeah also I know right like you do
yeah yeah usually MF oh yeah he must be
an infantry he was yeah yeah and
actually he got some awards and stuff
like that didn't see any combat or
anything I think he was in from 98 to
2001 I was after I was in yeah he's a
bit younger he was 34 when he got caught
in 2012 but it's interesting because
evidently he said he couldn't wait to
get out of the middle I to the military
he wanted to go into the military but he
said he couldn't wait to get out and
start killing people that's what he said
so the first crime that he actually
admits to he said it happened in 97 or
98 and he said that he was in Oregon and
he was watching a group of teenage girls
like inner tubing down the Deschutes
River and that one of them was kind of
slower than the others so he grabbed her
and raped her
and he was actually gonna kill her but
then he couldn't quite go through with
it
so he let her go now she never reported
it so they don't know who that is and
she would he wouldn't tell the
investigators her name so they don't
know who that victim is but that's the
first crime that he would admit to he
may have lied though but yeah he might
have made that up now the thing about it
is that the FBI are kind of thinking the
pattern the modus operandi they're like
this is a guy that has killed before
obviously so like I said they know that
he killed Samantha Koenig they know that
he killed the courier's they're pretty
sure he killed Deborah Feldman they
think that he committed at least four
murders in Washington State and they
think there are probably many more now
on the dark Minds documentary there was
this girl I can't remember what her name
was it was Molly
kolinsky I think was her name she was a
writer and she had made this big map of
the United States and she had made like
a timeline of where Israel Keyes had
been and they knew where he was because
of you know flight records rental car
records so she had made this map and
it's like you know I can tell that he
flew into this city on this date and his
rental car had 2000 miles on it so this
is the range yeah so what people are
trying to do now and if you go on the
website for him if you go on several
termini I think even the FBI website
might have this on it but it has a
timeline of where he was where he could
have gone because he would fly into a
city and then he would drive like a
thousand two thousand miles
somewhere else and he would always use
cash he would take the battery out of
his cell phone so nobody would know and
he would always pick he would usually
pick hiking trails you know kind of
remote like [ __ ] out in the woods like
in Washington State and he didn't have a
particular victim profile and he didn't
really care if it was a man if it was a
woman it was just whoever happened by
yeah you know he just wanted to kill
somebody he's like sometimes it was a
man sometimes a woman you know sometimes
it wasn't what you wanted but just
killer yeah it's just it's real killer
so it didn't matter it was just he was a
situational killer it was just whoever
happened to you know kind of walk
through his little trap that he had said
or whatever so now what they're trying
to do is kind of get the public's help
they're like here's the range where he
was at a particular time this is the
type of rental car he was driving then
if there are any missing-persons cases
from those areas from that time period
and they don't know what happened to
them particularly if they were out
hiking or if they disappeared from a
remote area and no one ever heard from
them ever again they think that it's
very very likely that he might have had
something to do with it
so it could be because he admitted he
said something about nobody ever knew
the real me I've always been to people
so the FBI guy is like well how long
have you been two people and he says
fourteen years so he's been doing this
[ __ ] for 14 years and he's dead now
thank heavens but so if he did it for 14
years how many people they know he
killed three people for sure they're
pretty sure he killed at least seven
more but I think there were probably way
more than that particularly because he
traveled a lot do a Google search on
Israel Keyes timelines and on web
sleuths there's like a whole somebody
has put up a whole thing like exactly
where he was exactly what kind of car he
was driving you know when it was like
further for the 14 years where he said
so I find it hard to believe now
sometimes he would go and just bury one
of his murder kits that he was going to
use later right so maybe not every time
he traveled maybe he didn't kill
somebody but maybe half the times and
that's a lot of times because he was
always always traveling and like I said
he robbed banks to get money he actually
made a pretty good living as a
contractor so he would just go on these
little quote-unquote vacations
you can rob banks entered with a
regularity I mean I don't think he did
it superb like I said he was doing that
he was pulling the same [ __ ] like he was
pulling with the burgers right no he
would fly to a city you know rent a car
drive to another city away far away you
guys rob a bank in the leave he'd beat
the [ __ ] out of there he's not from
there he's not reacted to that area he
was just drive to random places he's
getting getting away from the scene the
crime though tough it is yeah he but he
did get away with that I think he robbed
at least four banks that they know of
this every minute well yeah but he might
have done more and they were all in
different states he didn't want in New
York he did one in Texas he did one I
want to say New Mexico maybe but yeah
and he did a bunch of those too he was
also an arsonist is it that good as if
it wasn't bad enough and he did actually
say that he had um that he had set this
one place on fire but it seems like the
whole time and you could see that the
FBI is just like so frustrated because
they knew that there was all this
information and he had all this
information clearly but he would not
tell them and then they were like you
know we can't do they're trying to do
the the death penalty in a year and
stuff like that they couldn't do it
right so then he was only in custody I
think they arrested him in March 2012 in
December 2012 he slit his wrists and
hung himself with a bedsheet yeah yeah
he just wanted out so and he even said
in the interviews he's like you know if
you can't do you know the death penalty
at the time he's like I don't need you
guys alright even said that and then he
kind of laughed like I don't need you
guys to do it yeah so now he's dead and
all of these people that he killed and
I'm sure he killed a lot yeah well they
might never get found it could be could
be he's quite a got a quite a body count
out there but then on the other hand he
may have been lying true there's no way
of knowing they just got the waiting
scene but the thing is it's like like I
said if he wasn't gonna inflate his
numbers and tell everybody who I did
this that in the other right you know
why would he lie I would think that he'd
want to cash in but like I said he's a
different kind of offender or at least
he he purported himself to be there's no
way of knowing yeah he's gotta figure it
out on her yeah so I'm like super into
this now and now I'm kind of like low
because he actually was in Florida at
one point well we can always reverse
he came to Orlando for a foreign
vacation how long was he here not that
long it was only like a week or
something but that's long enough that's
long enough
was he alone over the Boise with his
family I don't think he ever brought his
family okay I think on that one cruise
then he went like I said the one
documentary that I saw where he went on
that cruise right after he killed
Samantha I think he took his daughter
but maybe not I thought but I don't
think it's great but his girlfriend and
his daughter didn't really seem to
suspect anything and all I can say now
like I'm I'm happy I mean I'm sure you
can find it cuz it's the Internet but
I'm happy that most things that talk
about him like everything I've read
about him they do not name his daughter
and I kind of hope I mean that poor
child she can only be she's probably
only 16 or 17 now so it's like god
damned if I was I would move I would
change my name holy [ __ ]
god that's got to be awful so I feel bad
for her I mean the girlfriend has been
named but she has a very common name so
she'll be alright hopefully but you know
they didn't have anything to do with it
didn't know what the [ __ ] was doing
but yeah this this dude man what was
everything else what a piece of [ __ ]
pretty much and I think I pretty much
covered everyone's read I can pretty
much cover water works are gonna
overpower you any minute yeah it sure is
yeah it's getting dark it's just turn
into 9:00 p.m. and it's dark so there's
no fireworks
all right so I hope you enjoyed if
that's the word this episode about the
very horrible Israel Keyes the serial
killer hopefully we can do a revisit on
it if they you know find some other
crimes that he committed which I kind of
hope they do I'm gonna sort of keep up
with it because it's I find it really
fascinating remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you would like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock or you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also
remember to check out our latest movie
review which was the George Romero
vampire movie Martin from 1978 and also
remember to check out our Zazzle sword
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and check
out all our new t-shirts as well as our
old ones they're all pretty cool and
that'll do it for episode 99 we will see
you next time on the
big 100th episode bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]